not just because I'm older and grayer
[Applause]
[Music]
I hadn't seen that yeah Michelle Obama
is late to watching October's viral
video he's got a little swag you know
that's okay when hubby Brock got quite
the compliment while stumping during the
midterm election I have to admit that
sometimes going out on the campaign
Trail
feels a little harder than it's Houston
not just because I'm older and grayer
[Applause]
said I was still fine
and the former president had the perfect
response I'm not going to tell Michelle
you said that
[Music]
although Michelle does a group
she knows we're getting distracted
but I want to show you something and I
you haven't seen I can't believe you
haven't seen it because we've all seen
it thanks to Jimmy Kimmel fans got to
watch Michelle's reaction in real time
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
well despite Brock's joke to keep it to
himself he actually ran home and not
only shared it he flaunted it you heard
about it came home that's the first
thing he said we gotta go somebody said
I was fine
sweet he's a stylish man who is healthy
and he's smart and he's passionate and
he's inspiring and who wouldn't fall in
love with that you know it's okay yeah
when it comes to the Obamas these two
are never shy about how much they adore
each other last month Michelle shared
these photo booth snaps on Instagram
I've lived in a number of places but as
far as I'm concerned I've only ever had
one real home my home is family my home
is Barack black and I we spend most
weekends we're staring at each other
because somebody's at a basketball game
somebody's at a dance somebody's
sleeping over we're the last people our
kids want to be with so I think they're
conditioning us for that emptiness
syndrome and 21 year old Sasha and 24
year old Malia have flown The Coop we
were gonna take him to dinner and they
said why don't you come over to our spot
for cocktails and we're like okay let's
see what this is gonna do and the first
thing they did well the martinis were a
little weak
I don't think they really knew what it
was
um but the thing I've heard about is
like when we got the glasses they were
like oh use a coaster what and I'm like
you never used a coaster
whether they're hanging with the kids or
prioritizing time together one thing's
for sure the Obamas know how to laugh
and have a good time you heard about it
came home that's the first thing he said
you gotta go somebody said I was fine
I was like oh really that's so sweet
foreign